that my sleep wipe is what okay
yeah all right so how do I do it okay
really not that hard what I'll do is
I'll think about both of these okay and
then it goes back to you remember black
first couple of weeks we did addition
and subtraction functions okay so do you
think those individually okay well
that's good okay X plus one X plus one X
plus one usually looks like that just to
bomb the origin right so it doesn't just
bounce okay
happy with that now before I go on I'm
gonna write down the equations in the
branches okay so this is going to be the
regular part this will be okay what's
the other part by 2 X 3 okay yeah it'll
be it'll be thinner I'm actually going
to think about it I prefer addition of
functions so I'm gonna deal with -
absolute value of 2x plus 3
so I'm gonna do the bottom one okay yeah
2x okay usually it's gonna be steep then
plus 3 okay so it's gonna be like that
it's gonna be coming down like that okay
so this is one right so I guess 3 is
gonna be I should have drawn this bit
smaller
right so it's gonna go down at a
gradient - right so it's gonna hit here
at -1 - ha okay and then it's gonna
bounce now just be silly I true that
trap there I'm doing the other side okay
so this comes all the way down 1 2 3
okay now what do I do
this is actually quite easy where's my
red okay if I'm gonna add these two
together and I probably should have put
the equations here sorry
so this is - this is the norm okay
remember addition of functions is really
easy if you've got a nice concrete
points okay example here at minus 1/2
that's zero and this is something else
some other value okay so whatever that
other value is I'm gonna be there some
zero plus something is something in the
same way zero plus this enviable enough
whatever that is okay now what happens
in between them okay well I've got to
get from here to here straight line
straight line I'm going to end up with
another straight line right okay so
that's what that problems like now what
happens over here you've got this going
on at a grade of one you're destroyed
and gradient of - so which one takes
over
that's what I'm in here right so it's
gonna go off a greeny of negative one
reverse logic over here creating a -
grating of negative one so the grading
of to tango mother so this is going to
be increasing and the grading of one now
well spit I need to know about all of
these equations all right so then you
just take these branches and you add
them together so over here - x - 1 + 2 x
+ 3 so this is going to be x + 2 what
are in between but the negative one and
the other negative one okay so to be
minus 3x that explains why it's so steep
and the constants will be -3 -1 -4 + 1 x
+ 1 - 2 X - 3
so it's minus X and the constant will be
minus 2 so I kind of missed but you get
the idea of that okay so from there that
gives you an intersex that gives you
another intercepts and you can work out
what that one is
that's 1 minus 4 over 3